um dieses video zu starten muss ich wohl
nicht erwähnen dass der bubble tea
heikel ist es eröffnen immer mehr leben
und selbst auf youtube bringt dieses
getränk immer noch ordentlich klicks
damals im jahre 2010 gab es diesen hype
schon mal die nachfrage nach den süßen
test war so groß dass selbst mccafé
verschiedene sorten angeboten hat doch
für den bubble tesa ist zwei jahre
später schon wieder ganz anders aus als
untersuchungen gezeigt haben dass er
anscheinend giftig sein soll hat sich
dann doch nicht so als ganz wahr
herausgestellt aber das konnte die
meinung der gesellschaft nicht mehr
switchen und kurz darauf hatten die
meisten leben wieder geschlossen und
nachdem der bubble tea sechs jahre im
schatten gelebt hat kam er wieder zurück
und seit ungefähr zwei jahren steigt
wieder seine beliebtheit an weil die
auswahl an bubble tea leben in städten
wie berlin mittlerweile so groß ist und
das kultgetränk aus asien mit seinen
vier bis fünf euro auch nicht gerade
billig ist nimmt euch tante vanessa an
die hand und macht mit euch einen
wandertag durch berlin britischen locker
und komfort mit maske zu fuß und mit
ganz viel fun die starken unsere tour am
ostkreuz im bezirk berlin friedrich sein
das ist der bezirk mit den familien
kreativen und ganz vielen bars und
restaurants und yoga studios da gab's na
ja das trifft eigentlich auch auf alle
bezirke zu merklich gerade in windeln
die erste station ist das teehaus die
auswahl auf der karte ist vielseitig
aber übersichtlich sie haben hier und da
auch ein special aber es hat nichts mit
bunten bubbles und zu kriegen getränken
zu tun
diese wachsen
die waffen sind eine absolute empfehlung
sie sind traditionell taiwanesisch und
werden mit verschiedenen füllungen
angeboten
der sommer in berlin macht besonders
spaß ja ich weiß wir haben es im februar
gedreht aber bei 19 grad kam auf jeden
fall sommergefühle hoch wir haben hier
einmal einen fruchtigen t mit passion
fruit orange und bisschen obst drin
ich glaube mit schwarz steht und hier in
deutschland favorite macho fabio capello
und habe mich nicht noch mal betonen
dass ich richtig froh bin dass sie halt
pappbecher benutzen papst strohhalme das
einzige was halt schade ist dass man
dadurch hat den schönen babbel teams
sieht aber ich finde die verpackung
sieht auch schön aus der nächste laden
auf unserer route ist ans teehaus an dem
tag haben sie aber leider geschlossen
berlin war ich hätte euch gerne ans
teehaus gezeigt in diesem laden hat mir
nie gezeigt und ist auch wirklich
delicious jetzt wo ernst herhaus zu
hatte mit einem tinnitus geht man nur
zur warschauer straße und auf dem weg
kommt man am rwe gelände vorbei
willkommen auf dem er es ist zitat das
größte zusammenhängende permanent
kulturell bespielte gelände deutschland
und die letzte noch nicht modernisierte
industriebranche innerhalb des s bahn
rings in berlin
coole bikes mit vanessa auf der
warschauer brücke kann man schon die
eastside mal sehen seit 2018 steht das
einkaufszentrum dort und wird nun ja
nicht so gut aufgenommen die toiletten
sind aber praktisch
[Musik]
muss ich sagen dass ich die nummer zwei
hier und dort gehe ich auch gerne zu kam
bei diesen möglichen gestaltete gebäude
eine sonnenbrille zu tragen
schon gehen laden kennt ihr vielleicht
auch schon aus dem test video und dort
habe ich auch meinen ersten perlen nicht
getrunken und falls sie es noch nicht
wisst es war liebe auf den ersten blick
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
da jede zelle meines körpers weiß wie
dieses ding schmeckt habe ich etwas
verrücktes genau wir haben ja immer den
roughs youku und bistros schwarztee
schwarztee und jetzt suchen wir uns ein
schönes plätzchen wo wir diese genießen
können
damit aus dem weg an die spree läuft man
über den mercedes benz platz und man
erkennt dass die investoren die seele
von berlin nicht ganz so verstanden
haben und einfach modern wirkende dinge
bauen um geld auszugeben und zu
verdienen und irgendwas mit aktien naja
an der spree ist es aber wirklich schön
also wenn man nach vorne guckt auf die
oberbaumbrücke oder halt auf eine ente
wir haben uns jetzt hier in diesem
wunderschönen platz besetzt wo sich
kreuzberg und friedrichshain küssen an
der spree direkt neben der baustelle
perfekt nachhaltigkeit es gibt papier
strohhalme und plastikbecher ich habe
aber auch im laden gesehen dass es so
wieder verwendbare gibt und ich habe
glaube ich sogar ein zuhause ich glaube
ich habe einmal gekauft 123 okay das hat
und als wir uns es dort gemütlich
gemacht haben wurden wir von jemandem
angesprochen der seinen eigenen t
herstellt und schon bei tapfer davon
sind so 34 stück drin mit tee nummer
zwei im bauch ging es an der east side
gallery entlang richtung berlin mitte
die east side gallery sollte man
eigentlich kennen
es ist ein stück der alten berliner
mauer welche mit kunstwerken geschmückt
touristen anziehen ich meine natürlich
berliner kultur zeigen soll
hotel
böhmermann und schön wir sind
dreieinhalb kilometer an der straße
entlanggelaufen am holzmarkt und katar
blau vorbei bis zum alexanderplatz und
ich achte darauf dass alexanderplatz
dort steht der fernsehturm dem man durch
souvenir geschenke wahrscheinlich schon
oft gesehen hat und dem man aus vielen
ecken von berlin aus sehen kann wo wir
jetzt in an ihm weiß ich nicht rallye zu
rallye auf unserer route hatten wir
glück und es sprang uns der nächste
party laden an boku tokio ist das was
sie als typischen bubble tea laden
bezeichnen würde ein sehr süßer tee mit
hunderten geschmacksrichtungen und
bunten babbel honigmelone jasmin grüntee
mit passion für babbels leicht grüne
farbe oder ein feeling von teekultur
bekommt man hier zwar nicht aber der
verkäufer war sehr nett und zuckrige
sachen verkaufen sich immer gut eine
million wahl war nicht so gut
keine melone marktwachstum melone
belohne
also ich glaube es bestimmt gut ich
glaube das war jetzt nur einfach zu
spontan
er war zu schnell für uns der war ja der
war zu schnell für uns wenn man auf
jeden fall so einen bunten bubble tea
haben möchte dann ist buwog oder weil
die haben so viele die hatten kirche als
diese diese perlen werten kirche
eigentlich jeden geschmack wie man sich
so vorstellen kann
und ja man krieg als und süßen tee mit
so einem süßen geschmack und bunten
bällchen drin vom alexanderplatz aus
kommt man über die münzstraße zu valley
wie elli wie englischunterricht mit
vanessa wenn ein e und ein a aufeinander
folgen spricht man will wie aus es ist
17 uhr 16 und vor der schlange die
ungefähr 30 leute beinhaltet alle
menschen gucken mich gerade an weil ich
rede wie eine reporterin
und das ist anscheinend in berlin das
coolste was man sich gerade angucken
kann wie ich hier mit kamera und
angenehm auf jeden fall sehr viele leute
vor der schlange für die schlange wurde
gerade die hasenohren dass ich nicht
drauf war wie elli ist das da wachs der
tee branche und verkauft sogar getränke
im supermarkt also wir haben uns jetzt
um entschieden wir haben es eben gerade
an die schlange gestellt aber sie ist
einfach zu lang und die leute haben auch
echt nicht so abstand gehalten muss man
sagen
deswegen haben wir noch einen anderen
marmelade in der nähe rausgesucht der
hoffentlich nicht so eine lange schlange
hat aber die hat nur noch 40 minuten
geöffnet also mit der hoffnung dass die
schlange später kürzer sein würde sind
wir los über die rosenthaler straße zu
pauken
an dieser stelle eine frage wie würde
ein bubble tea laden heißen schreibt
gerne in die kommentare während es
dunkel wurde und ich umringt von aus
gebürsteten t liebhabern war stellte
sich mir die frage ist es das wert eine
halbe stunde rumzustehen um etwas zu
trinken dass man ohne viel talent auch
leicht zu hause hinbekommt wie viel
koffein hält der körper eigentlich aus
und welche neuen crazy bunten sorten
werden uns wohl noch erwarten wir haben
uns jetzt einmal den
herren milch tee mit hosted genommen und
den timeless geholt noch gefragt was
deren an meistverkaufte winkels und das
ist hier dieser lila blau
basilikum mit einer ganzen litschi
teewasser cool findet er ist auf jeden
fall wieder verwendbar sie man kann sich
zu hause dann sein als die rein machen
oder man sehen wahrscheinlich hier noch
mal mit wenn man wiederkommt man hat
hier so einen kleinen verschluss
eröffnet man und hand genießt man
[Musik]
der blüte bringen
wir schon sehr lecker so schmeckt voll
nach litschi und gar nicht so süß was
sehr gut ist
hier haben wir den klassischen kerl
nicht für den hatten heute noch gar
nicht
und den habe ich wieder mit hafer nicht
gestellt das ist gerade richtig schön
durch die nacht mit an ihn war es halt
einfach auf 45 70
ich habe gerne in die kommentare
welche kulturen ihr noch sehen wollt
durch beginnen nun war es zeit für das
große finale wie elli bubble tea nummer
5 und definitiv einer der geheimsten
leben selbst um sieben uhr abends
standen hier genug leute um eine kleine
krone superstar diese veranstalten spaß
natürlich die bestseller wurden draußen
schon beworben und wir haben uns für die
nummer 1 und nummer 2 entschieden wenn
wir dieses format weitermachen dann
sollten wir wahrscheinlich immer die
bestseller bestellen was meint ihr
schreibt gerne in die irgendwie laktose
das heute den sehr guten job gemacht
es ist unglaublich wie wenig unangenehm
griffel man wird älter man wird
schmerzen haben auch im laden unsere
letzten babbel thies waren fertig und
und nicht in den feierabend verkehr der
s bahn zu geraten und die zweite super
sprayer party zu feiern haben wir uns
ein taxi nach hause genommen und wir
haben und den strawberry / iko der war
platz zwei und eigentlich ist er noch
cream cheese obendrauf das haben wir
jetzt weggelassen weil ich lag dose sie
vegan das macht keinen sinn da sehr süß
ich glaube wenn der cream cheese drauf
ist dann ist es echt geil
ich glaube ich bin sogar eher bei kerner
kerne
ich verstehe nicht warum ein beechey
lage ist uns lucky platz zwei ist aber
ich glaube zu sally gehen auch die
meisten leute für den creme brulée mit
habe mich creme brulée special
[Musik]
der schmeckt perfekt ich verstehe warum
sich so viele da angestellt haben
hmm lecker das war der große bubble tea
test in berlin welche party leben wie
yoga welchem bubble tea leben müssen wir
noch unbedingt ausprobieren welche
gibt's noch in berlin die absolut
empfehlenswert sind schreibt es gerne in
die kommentare wenn es die partie leben
die wir getestet haben in berlin auch in
eurer stadt gibt dann schreibt auch
gerne in die kommentare
und was mich sehr interessieren würde
ist was für eine future ihr noch sehen
wollt rahmen vegan burger schreibt gerne
in die kommentare und wir sehen uns da
müssten sie wieder und ich fünfmal heute
babbel tee trinken